soll jetzt nachdem corona zwangs tests
an flughäfen wohl beschlossene sache
sind die korona zwangsimpfung kommen
sowie die bundesregierung bisher
reagiert hat ist das nicht ganz von der
hand zu weisen auch wenn es immer wieder
dementiert wird klar ist dass impfung
unzählige leben gerettet haben und immer
noch retten doch welche risiken gibt es
und wie sinnvoll ist eine impfung klicks
um science in future hier gibt es drei
mal pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann und nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
kriegsfuß science im future gibt es
übrigens auch als podcast auf die ohren
die links zu spotify und apple podcast
sind unten in der video beschreibung auf
jeden fall anklicken
mit jedem super straight ereignis bei
dem also ein infizierter mehrere andere
menschen ansteckt zeigt sich wie
aggressiv corona tatsächlich ist da
werden mal 50 infiziert dann mehr als
100 turniers waren es mehr als 1500 das
virus ist extrem aggressiv und auch die
folgen der krankheit selbst bei
harmlosen verlauf können komplette
arbeitsunfähigkeit bedeuten ein gutes
beispiel dafür dass impfungen leben
retten ist schon einige jahre her die
rede ist von der einführung der
schluckimpfung gegen kinderlähmung
anfang der 60er jahre 1961 waren in der
bundesrepublik knapp 4.700 kinder an
kinderlähmung erkrankt eine wirklich
tragische erkrankung weder damals noch
heute ist polio sowie kinderlähmung auch
genannt wird heilbar
bei dem betroffenen kommt es unter
anderem zum lähmungserscheinungen an
beinen und armen und der atmung eine von
200 polio infektion führt zu lebenslange
lähmung bis zu zehn prozent der
gelähmten sterben wenn die atmung
aussetzt zwei virustypen aus der gruppe
der rna viren gelten als auslöser
diese werden vor allem durch
schmierinfektionen in diesem fall durch
kot übertragen das ist wirklich eine
sehr grausame und unheilbare krankheit
und in deutschland haben wir das glück
dass wir aufgrund der impfung seit fast
30 jahren keine polio infektion mehr
hatten
das ist ein riesiger erfolg doch in
pakistan afghanistan und nigeria ist die
krankheit noch immer weit verbreitet und
tritt auch immer wieder mal in
mindestens sieben weiteren ländern auch
fachleute raten deswegen eindringlich
davor sich auch hier in deutschland gibt
zu lassen denn nur so können
eingeschleppte fälle verhindert werden
doch in deutschland stehen immer mehr
menschen impfen kritisch gegenüber oder
werden einfach impfmüde in einem
positionspapier der deutschen
gesellschaft für allgemeinmedizin und
familienmedizin heißt es in deutschland
sind die durchimpfungsraten in den
ersten lebensjahr für die wichtigsten
impfungen sehr gut für die erste dosis
mmr sind beispielsweise in der region
der neuen bundesländer in fragen von 95
prozent erreicht welches ein ziel
kriterium für die ausrottung von
infektionskrankheiten darstellen ab dem
frühen jugendlichen alter lassen die
raten empfehlungs gerecht geimpfter
jedoch rasch nach bei erwachsenen und
älteren bürgern ist der impfschutz
gemessen an den imf empfehlungen der
stiko mehrheit licht unzureichend heißt
also im klartext lange nicht alle
deutschen im erwachsenenalter haben
einen vollständigen impfstatus das
schieben die allgemeinmedizinerin und
mediziner zum einen auf die
impfbereitschaft der menschen zum
anderen liegen die zu niedrigen
durchimpfungsraten bei wachsen personen
wohl auch daran dass nicht alle
hausärztinnen und hausärzte den
impfstatus ihrer patientinnen und
patienten im blick haben
zudem gibt es auch viele eltern die sich
dazu entscheiden ihre kinder nicht
impfen zu lassen ihre argumente reichen
von sätzen wie impfung fördern allergien
bis hin zur impfung verursachen die
krankheiten gegen die sie schützen
sollen die liste der einwände gegen das
impfen
die ist lang vor drei jahren hatte die
bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung eine repräsentative studie zu
dem thema veröffentlicht die große
fragestellung lautete hier aus welchen
gründen entscheiden sich eltern dagegen
ihre kinder impfen zu lassen
am 1100 eltern wurden befragt und 15
prozent davon hatten die folgende
befürchtung nämlich dass eine impfung
ihr kind körperlich zu stark belasten
könnte und sie es aus diesem grund nicht
impfen lassen wollten
die meisten ärztinnen und ärzte dagegen
empfehlen eine lange liste an impfung da
das menschliche immunsystem dadurch in
die lage versetzt wird sich gegen
erreger zu wehren und das funktioniert
so inaktive also nicht infektiöse
krankheitserreger also die also die
krankheit nicht auslösen oder aber deren
bestandteile werden bei einer impfung
verabreicht das immunsystem erkennt die
unerwünschten eindringlinge und beginnt
mit der abwehr
obwohl es keine richtigen intakten
erreger sind wenn der körper dann erneut
mit solchen
richtigen erregern dann konfrontiert
wird kann sich das immunsystem erinnern
und wir sind gegen diese erreger im denn
der körper erkennt dann die antigene der
erreger und ist durch die impfung in die
lage versetzt worden sich schneller zu
werden durch eine impfung gibt unser
immunsystem für den ernstfall
die wissenschaft weltweit was sehr viel
über das thema denn die geschichte des
impfens ist lange und hatte quasi schon
um das jahr 1000 nach christus begonnen
denn damals hatte man in china bemerkt
dass menschen die die pocken überstanden
hatten danach gegen diese erkrankungen
immun waren diese erkenntnis führte
damals dazu dass kinder absichtlich mit
pocken angesteckt wird nach ende des 19
jahrhunderts hatte sich da nur pasteur
ausführlich mit der entwicklung von
impfstoffen beschäftigt der münchner
facharzt für kinderheilkunde martin
hirte schreibt in seinem buch impfen pro
und contra dazu die ersten impfstoffe
waren nach heutigen kriterien schlecht
gereinigt und hatten enorm viele
nebenwirkungen der pockenimpfung viel
nachweislich tausende menschen zum opfer
bis zum zweiten weltkrieg waren
impfungen zudem nur für die
bessergestellten bevölkerungsanteile in
den westlichen industrieländern
zugänglich dann aber starteten die
ersten großen impfkampagnen und zwar in
den 50er und 60er jahren in den usa und
europa die große vision zum ersten mal
überhaupt eine ganze krankheit
auszurotten und das weltweit
1980 war es dann soweit und die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who erklärte
die erde als brocken frei in deutschland
wurde die pocken impfpflicht zwei jahre
später aufgehoben
doch nicht nur die pocken sondern wir
anfangs auch schon beschrieben der
rückgang der kinderlähmung kann auf
impfprogramme zurückgeführt werden auch
bei weiteren erkrankungen wie etwa mumps
masern röteln und diphtherie ist genau
das der fall
an dieser stelle ganz besonders wichtig
eine hohe impfquoten hat enorm positive
auswirkungen auf ungeimpfte personen wie
beispielsweise chronisch kranke oder
aber sollten diese gruppen haben nur ein
schwaches immunsystem und medizinerinnen
und mediziner ist es deswegen nicht
möglich diese person zu impfen und somit
zu schützen
die ständige impfkommission stiko am
robert koch institut in berlin
beschäftigt sich mit fragen zu
schutzimpfungen in der theorie und
praxis und gibt entsprechende
empfehlungen heraus auf der webseite des
robert koch instituts wird das
aufgabenfeld des expert
gremiums folgendermaßen definiert die
ständige impfkommission stiko entwickelt
impfempfehlungen für deutschland und
berücksichtigt dabei nicht nur deren
nutzen für das geimpfte individuum
sondern auch für die gesamte bevölkerung
die stiko orientiert sich dabei an den
kriterien der evidenzbasierten medizin
sprich hier steckt ausschließlich
wissenschaftlich bestätigt das wissen
dahinter
es gibt keine personengruppe die in
deutschland mehr über das impfen weiß
und dass eben wissenschaftlich fundiert
den empfehlung sollte man demnach also
eigentlich blind vertrauen können und
das machen die meisten erste weil sie um
das fachwissen dort wissen doch die
stiko stand in der vergangenheit hart in
der kritik dazu schreibt martin hirte in
seinem im jahr 2015 erschienen buch zehn
der 17 stieg um mitglieder weisen
teilweise gravierende
interessenkonflikte auf und nehmen oder
namen gelder von firmen über deren
produkte sie entscheiden doch seit 2008
müssen die mitglieder selbst auskünfte
zu eventuellen interessenskonflikten
geben dabei gilt als interessenskonflikt
bereits eine tätigkeit für ein
unternehmen bis zu zehn jahre
vor der berufung in die stiko diese
expertinnen und experten sind dann von
der beratung von impfempfehlungen
ausgeschlossen wenn sie für ein
unternehmen werbend aufgetreten sind
oder wenn auch nur die besorgnis der
befangenheit vorliegen könnte seit 2012
sind die sitzungsprotokolle zudem
öffentlich zugänglich also jeder und
jeder kann jederzeit nachprüfen was da
gelaufen ist doch in sachen impfungen
geht es nicht nur um den schutz des
einzelnen sondern vor allem auch um
epidemiologische und politische ziele
das ziel ist es die allgemeinheit vor
seuchen zu schützen und eine
herdenimmunität zu schaffen dadurch dass
sich ein großteil der bevölkerung impfen
lässt sinkt auch die
erkrankungswahrscheinlichkeit für die
ungeimpften medizinethikerin untätig
sind der ansicht dass jede und jeder
einzelne von uns eine art moralische
verpflichtung habe zu diesem
herdenschutz beizutragen
denn eine impfpflicht gab es in
deutschland bis anfang des jahres nicht
mehr
nachdem die pocken impfpflicht vor knapp
40 jahre 1982 abgeschafft wurde
noch anfang märz diesen jahres 2020 war
ein gesetz in kraft getreten nachdem
kinder zweifach gegen masern geimpft
sein müssen bevor sie den kindergarten
oder eine schule besuchen auch für
erzieherinnen und erzieher sowie die
lehrkräfte in der schule gilt diese
regelung der berufsverband der kinder
und jugendärzte hatte dazu mitte juni
ein positives fazit gezogen
dazu der sprecher jakob maske einige
eltern die sich bisher gesträubt haben
zu impfen nehmen es jetzt
zähneknirschend hin eltern die ihre
kinder nicht impfen lassen und in einer
gemeinschaftseinrichtung betreuen lassen
wir gehen dem neuen gesetz zufolge eine
ordnungswidrigkeit bis zu 2500 euro
geldbuße müssen gezahlt werden kurz zum
hintergrund mit einer impfpflicht wird
das ziel verfolgt impflücken in der
gesellschaft zu schließen nach angaben
des robert koch instituts hatten rund 97
prozent der schulanfängerinnen und
anfänger im jahr 2009 10 die erste
masernimpfung bekommen bei der zweiten
entscheidenden impfung dagegen sei die
angestrebte impfquote von 95 prozent
noch immer nicht erreicht die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wer ist sich
aber sicher wenn 95 prozent der
bevölkerung geimpft wären greift der
herdenschutz und erreger können sich
nicht mehr ausbreiten masern ließen sich
also komplett ausrotten und damit sind
wir beim thema auch in sachen corona
impfung wurde in der vergangenheit immer
wieder über eine mögliche impfpflicht
diskutiert rechtlich gesehen wäre diese
jedenfalls möglich bei einer aktuellen
umfrage eines
meinungsforschungsinstituts würde sich
die mehrheit der deutschen für eine
impfung gegen cupid 19 entscheiden als
sicher oder wahrscheinlich gaben 67
prozent der befragten an im vergleich
mit anderen g7-staaten liegen wir damit
allerdings ganz weit hinten nur in
frankreich ist die bereitschaft sich
gegen coop 19 impfen zu lassen noch
kleiner die impfbereitschaft liegt hier
bei 58 prozent
eine impfpflicht spricht in gewisser
weise allerdings gegen das
selbstbestimmungsrecht eines jeden
einzelnen so sagt die ottawa kater der
weltgesundheitsorganisation aus dem jahr
1986 gesundheit entsteht dadurch dass
man sich um sich selbst und für andere
sorgt dass man in die lage versetzt ist
selber entscheidungen zu fällen und eine
kontrolle über die eigenen
lebensumstände auszuüben
die auseinandersetzung zwischen im
skeptikern und befürwortern sind
jedenfalls enorm in manchen
veröffentlichung wird sogar gefordert
dass eltern im zweifel sogar die
verantwortung für ihre kinder entzogen
werden sollte dazu der kinder hat
michael sturm vor einigen
eine unterlassene impfung entspricht
einer unterlassenen hilfeleistung ja und
die ist strafbar dennoch gibt es auch
einige wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die sich für eine freie
impfentscheidung aussprechen und die
selbstbestimmung über die gesundheit
gefährdet sehen in einer diskussion zu
masernimpfung schreibt der
medizinethiker steven patterson im jahr
2001 die impfentscheidung ist für eltern
ein moralisches dilemma und dies muss
respektiert werden wissenschaftler
sollten sich hüten angst und
zurückhaltung als ignoranz zu betrachten
informierte ablehnung muss in einer
freien demokratie eine wahlmöglichkeit
bleiben was ist also eine informierte
ablehnen und quellen sind sicher nicht
studien von ärzten die danach sogar ihre
approbation verloren haben also
berufsverbot sowie der brite andrew
wakefield der meint herausgefunden zu
haben dass die kombinationsimpfung gegen
masern mumps und röteln mmr autismus
auslösen könnte seine studie konnte von
anderen forschenden nicht belegt werden
und dann kam heraus dass seine studie
unter anderem von anwälten finanziert
worden war die eltern von autistischen
kindern vor gericht vertreten
das geht natürlich gar nicht die mit
autoren zogen ihre autorenschaft zurück
und die wissenschaftliche zeitschrift
lancet zog die gesamte veröffentlichung
zurück ein absolutes desaster und auch
ansonsten im internet kursierenden
verschwörungstheorien natürlich nicht
aber es gibt dennoch immer wieder
beispiele von negativen folgen von
impfungen also welche risiken und
nebenwirkungen sind also wirklich bei
impfungen zu befürchten enthalten sind
im serum neben dem eigentlichen
wirtschaft noch zu setzen die
grundsätzlich als gefährlich gelten
können zumindest ab einer bestimmten
konzentration
die rede ist von aluminiumhydroxid
formaldehyd phenol oder
quecksilberverbindungen letztere sorgen
für eine längere haltbarkeit und
aluminiumhydroxid hat den vorteil dass
durch dessen zugabe weniger antigene
enthalten sein müssen so wird der
impfstoff verträglicher doch klar ist
auch dass aluminium einen euro toxischer
stoff ist und studien zeigen dass
bereits das einspritzen kleinster mengen
von aluminiumsalzen dramatische
auswirkungen haben
so muss die konzentration solcher
zusatzstoffe in den impfstoffen selbst
deutlich unter den grenzwerten liegen
ähnliche probleme auch beim zusatzstoff
weg silber und so hat die europäische
behörde für lebensmittelsicherheit
beschlossen dass das
konservierungsmittel thiomersal aus
impfung entfernt werden muss dennoch ist
natürlich klar dass man bei jeder
medikation mit nebenwirkungen rechnen
muss und das ist nicht nur bei
halsschmerzen betten und nasenspray
sondern natürlich auch bei impfung
allerdings bewegen sich die zahlen
anerkannter impfschäden zwischen 30 und
40 pro jahr in deutschland beantragt
werden um die 200 das sind beides
verschwindend geringe zahlen bei
haushalts unfällen sterben dagegen jedes
jahr rund 10.000 menschen wer also gegen
das impfen ist sollte auch nicht mehr
putzen so jedenfalls so mancher
impfbefürworter um für sich selbst eine
entscheidung zu treffen sollte man sich
also ausführlich informieren und seriös
beraten lassen um dann das risiko von
krankheit und impfung sorgfältig
abzuwägen und natürlich ist auch eine
impfung eine belastung für den körper
aber wir treiben ja auch sport und
schicken unsere kinder zum
sportunterricht und wissen um die
positive wirkung von dieser belastung
für den körper bei den standard
impfungen ist die sache klar diese haben
sich über jahrzehnte hinweg bewährt
nebenwirkungen sind bekannt und
dokumentiert und eben sehr gering
anders als beispielsweise bei der
schweinegrippeimpfung die nicht nur
innerhalb kürzester zeit sondern auch im
großen maßstab ausgebracht wurde und
nicht zu vergessen es geht weniger um
einen selbst sondern um sein soziales
umfeld das bringt man im schlimmsten
fall in lebensgefahr wie ein elfjähriger
junge der am 17 mai 1999 in einer praxis
in bad salzuflen fünf kinder mit masern
angesteckt hatte zwei davon starben
später manche menschen zweifeln die
wirksamkeit von impfungen gänzlich an
und setzten dagegen auf eine gesunde
lebensweise und ernährung gegen
letzteres ist auch gar nichts
einzuwenden denn beides stärkt natürlich
die widerstandskräfte gegen
krankheitserreger ganz sicher nicht aber
bieten sie einen sicheren schutz vor
tetanus oder kinderlähmung und wir sehen
bei corona auf erschreckende weise wie
kerngesunde fitte menschen von dieser
krankheit zu gerichtet werden
die verteufelung von im programm ist
irrational
denn nicht erst seit heute wissen wir
dass impfung wirksam
gefährliche krankheiten schützen und
somit auch ihre berechtigung haben und
sie sind eine tatsächlich natürliche
medizin die wirkung entfalten nämlich
nicht irgendwelche chemikalien wie bei
kopfschmerzen zb aspirin sondern die
natürlichen krankheitserreger die daran
gehindert werden die krankheit wirklich
auszulösen
tetanus krämpfe bis die knochen brechen
was nämlich passiert wenn man sich nicht
gegen tetanus zum beispiel geimpft hat
das ist schon ziemlich beeindruckend vor
allem schlimm also anklicken anschauen
und abonnieren einfach medizin sehr sehr
cooler medizin kanal mit abonniert
pflicht auf jeden fall also bis dann
bleibt dran